[Applaus]
voller Hoffnung sind sie nach Doha
geflogen brüllen ihr Team nach vorne
am Ende werden sie ja blaues Wunder
erleben wie fühlt es sich an dieser Tag
dieses Drama aus der Sicht von zwei
Fußballfans hier in Katar
Fanclub Nationalmannschaft Außenstelle
Dubai hier residieren zusammen mit rund
150 Fans auch Michael Kruska und Stefan
Zeitz seit der WM 2014 fahren sie
zusammen los kein großes Turnier mehr
haben sie verpasst ein 4 Sterne Hotel
mitten in der Stadt mit allem Luxus in
Doha hat der Fanclub kein passendes
Hotel gefunden deshalb dieses
Ausweichquartier angenehmer Nebeneffekt
hier wird richtiges Bier serviert und
das zu deutschen Preisen die Frage nach
der Klimabilanz hören Sie natürlich
ich sag jetzt mal 5600 km in ein
Flugzeug zeigen müssen und dabei die von
Katar teilweise auch und von der FIFA
ausgerufen der positiven Umweltbilanz
eigentlich gar nicht herzustellen ist
und nicht zu sagen
das ist so nicht die Fans hier verweisen
gerne auch auf die nächste WM in den USA
Kanada und Mexiko mit deutlich weiteren
Flügen von Spiel zu spielen
los geht's zur Stadtrundfahrt
durchs Zentrum von Dubai eine Menge
Sehenswürdigkeiten warten auf die Fans
und dann fahren wir weiter nach Dubai
Marina und am Ende fahren wir zusammen
nach dubaimund und in Türkei Moll ist
die wurzelt und die fahren hoch bis 125
hier gibt es auch allerlei Lampen zu
kaufen der Flair von 1001 Nacht weht
durch den Markt
Geruchsprobe am traditionellen Gewürzen
bevor es zum Schluss dann noch aufs Boot
geht von der einen Seite des Wassers auf
die andere dann aber früh ins Bett das
erste deutsche Spiel ruft
[Applaus]
Katha Doha International Airport am
Morgen
160 Shuttle Flüge kommen hier an täglich
in Scharen auch deutsche Fans es ist
kurz vor elf als Michael Koska Daniel
Rohde und Stefan Zeitz katarischen Boden
betreten mit dem Kopf haben sie
natürlich das ganze gezerrt um die one
love-binde
jeder Körpers also eine gewisse
Anspannung ist da auch eine Vorfreude
und man darf gespannt sein was jetzt
tatsächlich die deutsche Mannschaft sich
einfallen lässt bezüglich der
Repressalien die sie hier von Katar
selber aber insbesondere auch von FIFA
und DFB ja dann übertragen bekommen hat
von dem Tag erwarte ich natürlich dass
wir ein gutes Spiel hinlegen und auch
die drei Punkte einsacken
ansonsten vom Gefühl her ja das Winter
und WM ja etwas schwierig man ist jetzt
doch ein bisschen angespannt so vom
Spiel her und froh da zu sein ist auch
warm in Tuba was gerade noch kälter man
hat im klimatisierten Flughafen aber
jetzt ist alles wieder okay jetzt aber
wird doch langsam kribbelig
[Musik]
ein Foto fürs Fan Album so viel Zeit
muss sein bleibender Erinnerungen von
der WM in der Wüste
Einsteigen in den Shuttlebus erstmal in
Richtung Zentrum von Doha
die WM-Helden immer fest im Blick
die nächste knifflige aufgabewechsel in
die Metro einfach ist anders
kennengelernt haben sich die drei über
den Fanclub Nationalmannschaft das
Kennenlernen von Land und Leuten von
anderen Fans das ist ihnen auf den
Auswärtsfahrten immer das Wichtigste
die Metro hier wurde übrigens in fünf
Jahren aus dem Boden gestampft nur eines
von vielen Prestige Objekten das Katar
mit Hochdruck vor der WM umgesetzt hat
nächste Station Khalifa international
stay
[Musik]
ja die einzige sind recht positiv also
scheint doch ein recht offenes Land
miteinander hier zu sein wir sind
natürlich als deutsche Weide in der
Unterzahl ist ein Auswärtsspiel für uns
das ist ja ein bisschen komisch halt
aber ja Gefühle davon möchte ich nicht
sprechen aber es ist schon überwältigend
wir haben ja die ganze Zeit uns
ausgemalt wie es sein würde ist jetzt
noch mal ganz anders ist aber trotzdem
natürlich fantastisch also ähm ich will
jetzt bei den 30 Grad nicht von
Gänsehaut sprechen mache ich auch nicht
äh Gänsehaut Entzündung sagt der
Borussen wäre nicht immer für dich so
sehr schwere aber es ist schon
ein Erlebnis
schon zwei Stunden vor dem Anpfiff
machen sie sich dann auf den Weg in
ihren Block es wird eine Berg und
Talfahrt der Gefühle mit bitterem Ende
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ja wie soll ich mich nach dem Spiel wohl
fühlen also das ist eine der größten
Enttäuschungen ich habe nicht damit
gerechnet dass die deutsche
Nationalmannschaft unter Hansi fliegt
immer noch nicht in der Lage sein wird
ein besseren und auch den überaus
durchschnittlichen Gegner
kontrollierenden Fußball zu spielen hat
sich jetzt hier getan haben wir haben
dann enttäuschendes Spiel gesehen in
unserer Mannschaft und natürlich das
wm-gefühl das war ein ganz schwierigen
Stadion zu finden es war überhaupt keine
Stimme und an den Leuten und auch nach
dem 1:0 hat es sich nicht sehr viel
verbessert und das war natürlich danach
abgeliefert haben dann Fußball das war
pomatisch ohne Leidenschaft war
eigentlich gar nichts keiner
Weiterentwicklung hat man gesehen vom
Jogi Löw Fußball
und was sagen die zwei zu dieser Geste
es ist natürlich schwierig für die
Spieler ein Zeichen zu setzen auf diesen
verboten durch die Fieber aber das ist
besser wenig nix also sie haben sich
auch Gedanken darum gemacht dann hat man
gemerkt aber ja aber irgendeinen Erfolg
hat frage ich zu bezweifeln okay wenn
man schon nicht in der Lage ist hier das
Zeichen zu setzen dass man will und
damit einer gewisse Hilflosigkeit an den
Tag legt dann da mache ich gar keinen
Vorwurf dann ist es auch mit einer roten
Rückennummer für den Torwart oder mit
dieser Geste wir halten uns die Hände
vom Mund äh dann ist das zwar etwas
hilflos aber es zeigt schon dass ich
auch die Spieler mit der Situation hier
vor Ort auseinandergesetzt haben Michael
Kruska und Stefan Zeit ziehen betröppelt
ab es kann nur noch besser werden sonst
ist die erste WM in einer arabischen
Land schnell vorbei
ganz anders die Laune bei den
japanischen Fans vor dem Stadion sie
können ihr Glück kaum fassen
[Musik]